mr. cannon you're here I have actually
spoken to your lovely date Maggie
already you have an advantage because I
have yet to well I spoke to her on the
phone on the radio but I have yet to
meet her
now did you Instagram stalker before him
I wasn't allowed to yeah because you
know we're trying to make this as like a
true blind date like it's like a real
romantic comedy like like this is how it
really happened so I didn't I didn't
look at any profiles one thing one
suggestion I made I said hopefully I
don't want her to be like one of those
people that have like a huge social
media following is an influencer I just
wanted you know a regular everyday
individual you know I'm not looking for
anyone really but you know you're on a
date right but the idea of Valentine's
Day I'm a hopeless romantic so I was
like yo to be able to engage with
someone and and kind of you know just
have a real moment of those two always
being about on search and I'm looking on
single fall back on it that's
interesting though why do you say you're
not looking are you in that place where
you just feel because sometimes that's
when you find the person when you're not
trying to fix myself I'm trying to be
the best me I can be the best dad I
could be the best you know entrepreneur
and young media mogul that I could be so
I'm really just focused on me and being
the best because for some reason I
haven't gotten this relationship thing
right I'm not good at it I don't like
doing stuff now I'm not good at you know
what but that is when you become your
best self that's when you're in the best
place to find somebody looking within
okay let me ask you you you know you're
trying to be the best dad you can be do
the kids tell you like dad we want you
to find somebody my kids
it's the funniest thing my kids call me
a player I was like who taught you that
word this is who's been talking to you
and he's like that you can't be a player
forever the kids are calling you
eight-year-olds are calling you out well
we did ask Maggie and she has seen I
know you're saying you're not a player
but you do post those thirst trap
Thursday's yeah Maggie seen them next
she saw she says she likes some you she
gives you a like on-the-ground
inspiration that's just letting
everybody know you could you know be
tiptoeing on 40 and still look good
you've covered up here today you look
very dapper how did you
your outfit for the day you know what I
was you know it's kind of business
meeting vibes in like cuz I'm just
coming from a business meeting so I just
cleaned up a little bit but I kind of
had this almost of the day from the gym
I put part of this is a three-piece I
was in the other side just do the
overcoat on you know smooth the hair and
got good look from day to night exactly
so who do you get advice on your love
life from like that you know the kids
are calling you out I don't do you talk
to you know you said you made some
mistakes before Jenny the old
girlfriends or anybody give you tips on
what you should be doing better probably
on my show it's probably the only time I
really even talk about this stuff right
therapy therapy that's they get the best
advice my therapist gives great advice
she says what about the thirst trap
Thursday would that see because that's
not even though that is that's my I
can't answer that but how healthy I am
you know that it is you know I've had
some help condition so I'm saying like
look I'm in shape but it just so happens
if I get a few lights from some thirsty
people I'll take you so I know you're
not looking but what kind of woman would
you hope Maggie would be what are you
into attractive to tell me just being
her authentic self that's what and
that's rare these days of finding
someone who's comfortable with being
themselves and it's not you know
bombarded with you know the society's
perception of what a woman should be do
you get nervous at all before a first
date how do you approach it I've never I
don't get nervous I'm I got nervous like
fourth grade recital what's your move
what's Nick Cannon's first date like
first question you have a move no Nick
your child called you a player that
means you have a move make me within me
I don't know I like I'm silly I'm
something like I'm awkward like I'm not
something I'm comfortable being myself
so just laughter humor you know really
just engage in having a real
well we're very excited to see what
happens of course this all you don't
even be here the whole job we're gonna
wait till the end I'm gonna get your
thoughts Nick so this is how did come
like nah more like The Bachelor or
something like that you know you have
some wheat we got some shots of all the
red roses in here it's right in time for
Valentine's Day it is I was actually
gonna ask you I mean it was through your
morning show Nick so you you get put on
this date what was your reaction when
you found out I'm getting set up on a
date by my co-workers basically the
things I do for content is gonna horde
me out
so the morning show is going so well
tell me what you're liking about doing
that I'm loving it I mean number one
morning show here in Los Angeles I'm at
power 106 the most I kind of hip hop
station of all time so to get up each
and every morning I'm always up at 5:00
a.m. anyway to entertain people with
people that really come into my life
like this it's the most intimate form of
entertainment so I love it I mean you've
done so much we've loved you across so
many shows I gotta ask you about
America's Got Talent
could we ever see you returning to that
friends I love that show so much and I
wish everybody over there the best it
seems like you know they're probably
going through some things but I think at
the core of it it's America's show and
it's really about the people that wish
fulfillment of utilizing your gift to
get to another stage in your life and I
think people should just focus on that
so you never know I love this so much I
never wanted to leave you know what had
nothing to do with the creative it was
just more of a you know some some
business things or some inner workings
so I wish that showed the best and I
wish that franchise a bit like you said
he I mean Gabrielle spoken out about it
did you have a reaction when you heard
her story about that me and Gabby talked
all the time and it's just you know I
was just there to be our support system
and whatever she says I stand firmly
with it yeah absolutely
and just that we have to do that there's
no other choice I mean you know that's
though that's the point when someone
speaks up they're speaking up for a
reason
did you have experiences like that I
mean I've spoke do you remember I spoke
up quite loudly about but it was you
know I did it and ingest but there's the
realities in our business that you know
are quite harsh that we all deal with
them people deal with them differently I
mean obviously I have many platforms in
many ways to get out there and tell the
without you know going the way where you
know it has malice but I got to live my
troop and I got to speak my truth and
that's why I'm no longer there and then
I salute and applaud Gabby for making
the decisions that she's made is what I
do want to ask you about something that
is just kind of top of mind for all of
us as we head into what's going to be a
really emotional day which is Kobe and
his memorial coming up the public
memorial that we're gonna have will you
be a part of that in any way and how
have you been handling the past couple
of weeks it's been tough for everyone I
mean all I can be is a support system of
first family and all the families that
lost someone in horrific tragedy I feel
a certain way I'm probably one of those
people that you know after you pay your
own personal respects when the media
gets involved it gets a little weird for
me you know and I've been invited and I
you know I'm I'm a even you know visit
but I don't want to be I don't want to
host anything I don't want to be on
television talking about it because I
feel like it's at a certain point it
gets a gets to be a little bit too much
we're like how much are you paying
respects and how much are you taking
advantage or cloud chasing in a sense of
where it's like for the likes or for the
media and and I've always had a issue
with that when personal things occurred
you know even with the Instagram post
night is that really what we're supposed
to do is that's the way this generation
mourns or do we mourn internally or do
we you know for all of the fans I think
it's an amazing thing but for you know
other people in the media as just
someone who you know we do it on that we
did it in the morning on my show I
didn't want to make it about like Oh
Colin you know it was more about let's
have a moment of silence share your your
favorite Kobe moment or something that
we can internally do because someone who
actually you know had the opportunity to
meet him on many occasions he was he was
private he was he was a loving soul but
he was also like we got to keep it
moving
and that is that Mamba mentality so I've
paid my respects but I just don't want
to make it a media spectacle you know
like you said asking people their
favorite moment can I just ask you than
any piece of advice he gave you or a
moment you'll always remember
I always remember just I was surprised
of how in tune you know that to even
like whether it was wiling out or just
you know even he was a regular guy cuz
we viewed him even me I'm known at work
a beauty was like a superhero who's like
just lives in the gym so when he was
aware of you know everything that even
that I was doing I was honored I was
like yo and it's just a like if he if he
loved you he loved you you know what I
mean and he would always talk about
perseverance is sticking to it and the
drive and clearly you know his entire
career in his entire life was a
testament to that and that's what he
always spoke when every time I
encountered him masked singer are you
gonna go on the tour I'm not I got my
old tour I got a singer but I think like
I kind of have I have mass singer we got
the masked dancers happen and we got so
many other things that I'm doing I got
the wild and out tour the next season
awhile announcer that's the one thing I
probably don't have time to do next one
yeah and I think because I think the
tour is more about the actual characters
and the singers like I'm gonna go out
there do is show my shiny shoes so I
feel like that tour is gonna be great
but obviously you know we just launched
a while and out live tour we're doing
arenas all over the world so that's
gonna take up a little bit of time
alright well now it's time to get to
your date Nick Cannon that was good like
cuz that was like an icebreaker now I
feel like I'm relaxed you just had your
this was your intro date now you gotta
go thank you you were like the forward
to the date what a compliment thank you
that's the nicest thing a man's ever
said to me
you were the forward to the day laid it
all out like even if you don't want to
read the entire book
it was the boy let me ask you things go
well we're gonna check in with you after
but could there be a chapter two would
you ask this lady on the second
I'm Navy I mean that's how it works
right this is like as you're building a
love story you know chapter one chapter
two we'll see
okay we're brushing off the food you
just finished the date with Maggie how
did it go it was uh pleasantly pleasing
does that make sense that's means you
just said Pleasant and pleasing and
that's a double dose of good yeah cuz
I've talked about she was very authentic
it wasn't about like she weren't
interviewing each other yeah it was like
real conversation so in you know that's
kind of unexpected and then when you can
like obviously have a great meal but
then at the same time enjoy somebody's
companies who's cool and I'm an awkward
dater because I don't date what do you
mean you're awkward you're a charismatic
guy you're a host on TV but that's the
thing like I'm probably not as like
outgoing as people think because like
when I'm on I'm sorry but Nick you like
you get in like public beefs with people
so how are you but I'm a shy person
naturally like that's that's the
entertainment stuff I could do that all
day but like an individual like you're
being vulnerable and talking about so
I'm like a side guy naturally naturally
okay there aren't many different sides
of Nick I was actually thinking that I'm
like we get like performer Nick we get
host Nick we get today we have corporate
Nick the comedian Nick you get all of
that stuff but didn't like strip all of
that down this is calm fragile soul okay
I gotta ask you a weird question yeah
Maggie did tell me that she's she
listens to your show she also said she's
a Mariah fan did your ex come up on your
absolutely not wait I mean I might've
talked about of course I always talk
about my kids okay yeah I mean who isn't
a Mariah fan hi everybody I'm arriving
that happens all the time as I have an
on dates book yes of course as Mariah
giving you any tips on dating yeah don't
do it otherwise she's still family for
life so I you know we when we when we
talked no subject matters come up we
just kind of avoid it all right so you
have the date with Maggie here at your
amazing restaurant Yamashiro all good
and what will happen from here
from here that second date what we've
discussed it without cameras okay that
means it's real okay real yeah that's
what we definitely it's a real thing you
got a lot in common
she told she's a mom she's kids I'm a
dad she has a fourteen-year-old you were
listening I was out I was in tone it was
real okay yeah be I really be honest
right now what were your real feelings
you tracked it hurt let me see when you
say attracted of course cuz that but
that's physical I'm looking to be in
tuned with somebody aligned with
something I felt like we are aligned
aligned is more important than
attraction did you get her number
do people still do that what are you
gonna do I don't like you're gonna DM
her see y'all my slide and dance we know
how to get in contact with each other
all right well second date could happen
by the way I I googled this because we
were thinking about this after I talked
to you did you wear the two million
dollar shoes for this thing not not this
one not either D these are like the the
substitute ones I saved those for the
masked singer for the second date Betsy
that's kind of like I was trying not to
be too flashy if I would came in with
two million dollar shoes on I already
drove up in a Rolls Royce I mean trying
to be normal alright Nick well you were
normal she was authentic and date number
two could happen yes no the thing is now
you got that narrator wow we're really
writing a book here today if you guys
get married all this is on camera don't
believe in marriage anymore
are you serious yes see he's gonna break
me all the way down what you need me
don't believe in it anymore I mean my
mindset has changed I've done that I'm
not I told you I'm like doing big things
that I'm not good at we're bad at it you
got two beautiful kids you jumped out of
a plane one time and it didn't work out
that's what you're saying Mary you
wouldn't do it again would you just
compared marriage to like something even
died hug barely
survive why would I jump out of a plane
again rived here you are that is true I
mean I'm still working on growing I was
a broken soul and I'm growing now I'm
out I'm back out on the scene can I tell
you something really real right now yes
I don't think you don't vote I get what
you're saying I'm divorced I'm Devore
I'm but I think ya know well I know
where you're coming from but I think you
gotta meet the right person and then
maybe everything would you yeah you
never know it could be Meg
[Music]